but what I love about that that whole
your rants yeah your 60-second rants I
almost see in that either coming to life
or even seeing a live-action where
you're on stage where you introduce
something with that animation and then
going to stand up like it's something
that you go back and forth on oh that be
interesting show well one because
there's so many people that are doing
that that type of situation where
they're throwing like Hassan and and I
think Chelsea did it you know I mean and
they do that they use the visual but
nothing more original than yours like it
would be just you doing like your stand
up and then boom you throw it to it gang
yeah you know I mean and then you throw
to it just like how a poet intro his bit
right like I didn't yeah then go to Katt
Williams would enter like introduce a
panther into the [ __ ] or a tiger or a
tiger yeah he was like right in the
middle it is just right in the middle of
his joke he has six [ __ ] holding
holding holding an urn of some of
someone he heard but no one questions
what's in it but they know there's
something dead for sure
my mama's in this [ __ ] man he
was great man great are you kidding me
and here's the thing this is what I
don't like about the internet um you
only know the guy that you see that's
getting fifteen million views because
he's getting choked out by somebody or
he did something [ __ ] up in Ontario
you know you've all done something [ __ ]
yeah but but no one knows like are you
friends with because I'm friends with
him oh no I'm not friends with him I
wish I was I saw him I saw Katt Williams
one time yeah this is a craziest thing
yeah I was standing on the front porch
of the Comedy Store and you know
sometimes you see people that have those
bikes that have like the colors lit up
in the middle it's like the lights in
him and you're like there was a group of
you know kind of urban gentlemen driving
down the street together yeah and I
looked and uh and the main it was
buddy's cat Williams and this is like
four years ago
like this is hot not literally thirty
years ago and he was a kid this is like
there was just for you know legit
gentlemen it's cruising down the street
wait are you talking about motorcycles
or bicycle bicycles with those like lit
up like it's like fluorescent as it you
know as electricity going through the
some kind of a pipe
in the wheels and it's colorful so you
see these and I thought it was gonna be
four you know yeah under didn't cause it
was kind of gay colors yeah yeah but it
was uh for real deals man yeah yeah on
the street yeah and then you're like
that's Katt Williams I mean you know cat
we Louise he cat Williams yeah and it
was Katt Williams I go way back when he
had a show uh and at a casino and he
used to he'll put me up every now and
then this is way back man we're talking
like I'd have to say sixteen years ago
oh yeah it was someone and I think is he
used to go by Cat in the Hat
of really yeah I used to go by Cat mahat
my friend have a cat and they named it
Williams to me like oh that's cat would
that's pretty cool man but I'm talking
what the thing about cat is people don't
know how nice the guy is I've heard
amazing things he's so nice he adopts
all his kids he's got so many kids that
he adopts he was so nice to me I
remember I did BET's coming for you this
is so far back yeah and this is like I
didn't have you were black this is when
I was a black comic before I became a
Latino comic it wasn't like like 11
years when I was like wait a minute
I'm an Asian comic and I have a Filipino
mom with a voice hold on by the end
you're Michael Jackson oh my god and I
still did and I did the Apollo and I won
how's that at a black show yeah and then
uh and it was so funny because I I fly
into New Orleans and I forgot where we
were shooting it but I had no agent no
man anywhere there I just bought a plane
ticket it was a black show Black
Entertainment Television so they forgot
that I was even flying in no one picked
me up no bro
swear to God oh you know and I'm
standing there with another comic yeah
that was on the show I forget his name
yeah oh my god you know who else was on
that show was uh oh my god with a
straight uh uh wait no stop no come on
the little Duval was on that Duval this
was his first ever TV appearance real it
was a little Duval like and he was
really little like he was young like he
he earned the name little you know like
17 or some [ __ ]
it was 46 yeah no yeah no it's like
let's go to ball beat middle-aged Duval
you know the old Duval hole Duval or
elderly elderly Duval but uh but all I
know is I was standing there and I'm
just like I'm literally homeless bro I
had like 150 bucks to my name I'm trying
to get to this hotel I remember saying
to myself maybe I can catch the shuttle
I tried to pick up you know though you
know those phones that show you all the
hotels you pick it up and press the
number at the airport yes that [ __ ]
never works
yeah they never [ __ ] work man it
doesn't go to the hotels and a shuttle
yeah we'll send a shuttle like it's
literally it's usually a woman that
sounds like I could possibly doing it
it's somebody do an impersonation of a
black yeah it is saying oh we'll send a
shuttle yeah hang up it's a redheaded
one white chick dude in New Orleans that
goes through a Popeye's and they're like
uh drive around honey
what no I want to bed no band in this
box of chicken yeah look how about this
we put a uh side item under your pillow
let's call it a night yo you want the
Howard Johnson yeah Howard Johnson come
with a bacon mashed potatoes yeah come
around
what and we don't have them on a menu
but I have a couple of servers right
here in my purse Yeah right here you
couldn't yeah you gonna come around to
the next customer what are you talking
about what you own a bicycle come on hey
does it light up in the middle don't be
embarrassed drive around around yeah you
want a gallon of sugar tea yeah don't
bring a gun don't bring a gun don't
think we got good we got good
yeah I'm bout to [ __ ] dope this six
piece for the [ __ ] shotgun about to
shoot up this [ __ ] side you wanna a
keg real [ __ ] of drumstick yo what do
you want you are a little easy opinion a
little woozy fingers with hot mustard
what is that dip the end it is not gonna
Saran way to [ __ ] blow your brains
out
muddy way I just want to go to bed yeah
you got to go to bed you got to go to
the fun of this of threat yeah this
travel I'll pop on this Howard Johnson
[ __ ] this Howard Johnson Denny's
man but I can put syrup on your pill a
[ __ ] yo Grand Slam [ __ ] it's
definitely different in New Orleans it's
so different
so anyways I'm standing outside and cap
pulls up in a limo wow it just pulls up
like the limo cut well he doesn't pull
up the limo pulls up and he's and he
pulls up right behind me and he's like
Oh what you doing I'm like man they
forgot they forgot to send me a man just
getting in a cab me and I get in the car
he drives me we get to the hotel of
course my rooms not ready no Katz's they
got two people smoking in your room cat
got the whole cat got cat got the 13th
floor yeah you got nine you got nine
rooms and I'm just trying to wait for a
twin yeah and mine's not ready and he
takes me out to breakfast yeah like
that's the kind of stuff he does man and
he called you Gary oh and oh yeah come
on Henry Cho dude Gary Gary Owen
introduced me he needs to come out of
the Oise it bro and that's white people
that are actually black he needs to come
out of the [ __ ] was it good evening
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw I
mean it was okay but the next video you
can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one